herr hoffmann wir haben es gerade gehört
die ja kriminal akte ist erschreckend
lang einbrüche sexuelle missbrauch von
kindern aber auch vergewaltigung einer
72-jährigen ja wie passt das alles
zusammen zu einem möglichen
kindesentführung oder vielleicht sogar
einem mord tatsächlich dieser
widerspruch in dem in dem alter der
opfer ist in wahrheit kein widerspruch
sondern die größte gemeinsamkeit was
haben eine 72 jährige frau und ein
dreijähriges mädchen gemeinsam
es ist die wehrlosigkeit und oftmals
probiert diese art von personen in
vielen fällen ich kann doch keine keine
ferndiagnose machen und schon gar nicht
ohne mit ihm gesprochen zu haben aber
das was ich gesehen habe die akte das
urteil kann man schon sagen dass einige
merkmale der psychopathie da sind und da
geht es ganz oft um ein machtbedürfnis
das grundmotiv es macht es geht nicht
darum sich im finanziellen sinne zu
bereichern ja es gab auch drogendelikte
und einbruch aber dass kernmerkmale was
sich durchzieht und was was für ihn
wirklich wirklich kennzeichnet ist ist
sexueller missbrauch in verschiedenen
formen und dabei vergreift er sich an
den schwächsten der schwächsten warum
weil er an ihnen am einfachsten sein
bedürfnis ausleben kann
einmal ein machtgefühl zu haben
kontrolle zu haben und etwas zu
beherrschen und oftmals hat diese art
von person und diese art von profil im
leben sonst keinen weg gefunden das
auszuleben es wird zwar immer wieder
gesagt er war so charismatisch und
intelligent aber schauen wir uns das
profil anja hat den hauptschulabschluss
erfolgreich hinter sich gebracht war ein
heimkind hat dann aber die ausbildung
abgebrochen
eine erste beziehung ging in die brüche
seitdem nur noch gelegenheitsjobs und
flüchtige beziehungen das heißt keinen
festen und vernünftigen job über längere
zeit keine feste und vernünftige
beziehung ich meine man spricht immer
von psychosoziale isoliert aber das
bedeutet einfach dass er in vielen
lebensbereichen nicht das erreicht was
er sich eigentlich wünscht weder bei
frauen erfolgreich noch beruflich
erfolgreich und die kriminalität ist
dann der weg für diese art von typen ihr
machtgefühl einmal auszuleben und dass
er dabei ausgerechnet eine 72-jährige
und oder dreijährige mädchen oder kleine
kinder missbraucht das sind die
schwächsten der schwächsten und das ist
schon innerhalb der kriminalität auch
das armselig was man was man tun kann
und selbst unter kriminellen
gilt das als rotes tuch ja und wir haben
es gerade eben gehört es könnte sein
dass christian b vielleicht etwas mit
dem verschwinden der fünfjährigen inga
zu tun hat die auch seit fünf jahren
spurlos verschwunden ist
die polizei soll jetzt ein
bewegungsprofil erstellen wie genau die
polizei davor ja man muss sagen dass
kinder aus hotel resort anlagen entführt
werden ist absolut untypisch deswegen
hat auch dieser fall maddie mccann
global für schlagzeilen gesorgt weil der
modus operandi das vorgehen so
ungewöhnlich war einzeltäter einzelne
sexualstraftäter finden ihre opfer eher
im persönlichen oder nahen umfeld von
der familie bis hin zum sportverein und
organisierte kriminalität menschen haben
wir ja diese dinge gibt es natürlich
auch die entführten kinder aus sozial
schwachen vierteln oder finden ihre
opfer in der prostitution im
drogenmilieu und suchen sich da ihre
opfer sie entführen aber keine kinder
von einer ärztefamilie in portugal aus
einem ferienressort das heißt dieser
modus operandi war so ungewöhnlich dass
man dass er einfach aufgefallen ist und
weltweit für schlagzeilen gesorgt hat
der fall enger ist sehr sehr ähnlich und
deswegen ist es nur logisch dass man
jetzt die fälle die ähnlich sind mal
miteinander verknüpft und prüft ob sie
etwas miteinander zu tun haben
wenn ich mir anschaue was im vorjahr
passiert ist und was im fall maddie
mccann passiert ist dann sind die
parallelen offensichtlich jetzt gilt es
aber zu prüfen ob er wirklich was damit
zu tun hat und scheinbar war er zur
tatrelevanten zeit am tatrelevanten ort
genauso wie beim maddie mccann auch und
diese beiden dinge in verbindungen die
ähnlichkeiten im vorgehen bei der
tatausführung und die tatsache dass er
in beiden fällen vor ort war
das ist natürlich erstmal sehr starke
anfangsverdacht ein starkes indiz aber
nur weil er in der nähe war und ähnliche
vorstrafen hat heißt das nicht dass er
der täter ist aber das gilt es jetzt zu
prüfen aber ich halte die
wahrscheinlichkeit doch für ziemlich
hoch und dann wäre es sogar ein
serientäter oder sogar serienmörder ja
jetzt hat uns ein bekannter eben von
christian beeck gesagt das ja der
mordverdacht schon länger im raum stand
im sommer 2018 soll die schon einen
mordverdacht gegen christian b
vorgelegen habe er soll dazu befragt
worden seien warum dann erst jetzt zwei
jahre später dieser schritt dass er
tatverdächtig ist ja manchmal ist diese
ermittlungsarbeit der polizei ein
teufelskreis und oft wird dann auf die
deutsche justiz oder auch polizei
geschimpft nach dem motto warum haben
die das nicht schneller
gemacht wir haben einen rechtsstaat das
unterscheidet uns von vielen anderen
ländern und das ist auch gut so und
manchmal sorgt aber genau dieses prinzip
der rechtsstaatlichkeit für einen
teufelskreis die beweise sind
beispielsweise auf der festplatte oder
in dem haus aber um die festplatte oder
das haus zu durchsuchen brauchen sie
beweise das heißt die beweise die sie
brauchen um das haus zu durchsuchen sind
in dem haus
dieser teufelskreis ist extrem schwer zu
durchbrechen und da tun ermittler ihr
bestes und gerade in einem fall maddie
mccann kann man darauf wetten allein
wegen der immensen öffentlichkeit die
der fall geschaffen hat dass sowohl in
portugal als auch in london als auch
jetzt in deutschland mit hochdruck daran
gearbeitet wird diesen teufelskreis zu
durchbrechen so dass man genug beweise
hat die den anfangs bereit rechtfertigen
alles weitere zu durchsuchen und zu
überwachen
mittlerweile denke ich ist der
verdachtsmoment stark genug so dass man
alle möglichen arten von durchsuchungen
auch tun kann aber das braucht nun mal
zeit man kann ich einfach nur der
anfangsverdacht war anfangs gegen ihn er
war in der nähe und er hat ähnliche
vorstrafen aber das allein reicht nicht
um sagen zu können dass man jetzt seine
persönlichkeitsrechte einschränkt und
alle arten von durchsuchungen und
vernehmungen erlaubt mittlerweile denke
ich aber sind doch in summe die indizien
so stark dass diese durchsuchungen auch
möglich sind aber das braucht zeit gute
polizeiarbeit dauert lange
deswegen die polizei zu kritisieren dass
sie lange braucht ist denkfehler weil es
ist eher ein qualitätsmerkmal dass sie
lange brauchen
auch wenn das manchmal traurig ist und
man sich natürlich zu recht fragt warum
läuft so jemand noch frei herum wenn ich
mir die vorstrafen angucke glaube ich
schon dass manche urteile auch etwas
härter hätten ausfallen sollen